[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez bienvenue sur France 24 à la une
ce soir cette nouvelle attaque
djihadiste Tchad le bilan officiel fait
état d'une dizaine de morts l'attaque
est survenue dans la région du lac Tchad
une zone où le groupe Boko Haram
continue d'être très actif nous recevons
ce soir Jean-Bernard pas d'arrêt
ministre d'État Conseiller à la
Présidence et porte-parole du MPS nous
évoquerons avec lui la situation
sécuritaire dans le pays la France qui
pourrait retirer son contingent posté au
Burkina Faso annonce du ministre de la
Défense dans le JDD la raison invoquée
les troupes françaises seraient de plus
en plus décrié par les nouvelles
autorités et la population
la rencontre tunisie Danemark les Aigles
de Carthage sont soulagés après le match
nul face aux Vikings les supporters
tunisiens attendent les prochains matchs
avec impatience on les écoutera au micro
de notre correspondante
le bilan est encore incertain après
cette attaque terrorisme néo Tchad
officiellement une dizaine de militaires
tchadiens ont été tués ce mardi mais un
responsable de l'armée s'exprimait
s'exprimant dans l'anonymatoque de son
côté une trentaine de morts l'attaque
s'est déroulée aux abords du lac Tchad
pour en parler nous recevons
Jean-Bernard padaret ministre d'État
Conseiller à la Présidence et
porte-parole du MPS merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir sur ce plateau
alors tout d'abord quel bilan de
l'attaque une dizaine une trentaine ou
est-ce que le bilan est encore
provisoire et qui pourrait
s'alourdiridence qui fait état d'une
dizaine de nos soldats de nos vaillants
soldats tombaient glorieusement à malamé
et donc je pense que c'est le bilan
officiel il y a pas de raison de douter
de cela donc alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé exactement est-ce que vous avez
des informations sur sur cette attaque
vous vous souviendra que la semaine
dernière le président de la République
justement anticipant sur les menaces de
Boko Haram de cette pieuvre avait
effectué un déplacement
dans la province du lac Tchad et en
constaté la situation et ayant des
informations assez sûr avec décidé
d'envoyer 600 de nos soldats sur le
terrain donc
il y a une unité de
précurseur qui était allé sur une île et
donc oui exactement ils sont allés sur
une île et donc ils ont été victimes
d'une attaque surprise de Boko Haram qui
vous savez une île parce que ces gens
ils se cassent très souvent dans l'eau
ils ont surgi je pense que la réplique a
été foudroyante et d'ailleurs le
communiqué du porte-parole la présidence
le précise que le gouvernement était
instruit de façon à l'effet de ratisser
et de mettre
un terme à cette attaque là alors n'est
ce pas justement une réponse vous l'avez
évoqué le Président de la Transition
mamatidriss Déby s'est rendu sur place
il y a une dizaine de jours pour une
tournée dans la région et il avait
déclaré que les djihadistes ne pouvaient
plus s'attaquer au caserne est-ce que ce
n'est pas aussi une réponse à ce qu'il
avait déclaré est-ce que n'est-ce pas
aussi une façon de montrer qu'ils sont
encore très actifs moi je pense plutôt
que ces derniers soubresso d'une pieuvre
qui est en termes
est en train d'être éradiquer et donc
effectivement ils ont voulu
réagir de cette manière pour peut-être
signaler leur présente mais ça a plutôt
été une occasion et ça c'est une
occasion pour l'armée tchadienne d'en
finir avec je profiterai de votre
antenne pour dire en fait cette lutte
que le chat mène contre Boko Haram il
est seul le Tchad a mené cette lutte on
a besoin des pays des puissances
des pays européens américains bref de la
communauté de la communauté notamment
occidentaux comptent sur l'armée
tchadienne notamment dans le Sahel
compter sur l'armée parce que nous nous
finançons sur nos fonds propres cette
lutte qui est une lutte mondiale ce
n'est pas une lutte propre au chat parce
que le Tchad et le pays de France de
façon et nous luttons pour en fait nous
protégeons les autres pays mais sans
sans être aidé la situation du Tchad
aujourd'hui avec un pays qui se bat sur
plusieurs fronts sur sur dans la région
du lac Tchad mais aussi sur la frontière
au Soudan il y a plusieurs finalement
plusieurs fronts que vous menez quelle
est la situation sécuritaire au Tchad
aujourd'hui heureusement on a une armée
qui est assez sol
nous comptons un million 284000 km². il
n'y a pas un seul centimètre de nos
territoires qui est occupé par une
rébellion ou bien par une une horde de
mercenaire ou de terroriste quelconque
mais vous savez c'est pas évident de
mener cette lutte la seule pour un pays
qui n'a pas de ressources comme le chat
nous nous battons sur le plan social
nous ne partons pour la sécurité de
l'intérieur de notre pays pour nous
protéger contre les attaques pouvant
venir de l'extérieur mais nous avons
besoin en plus de cette lutte militaire
qu'on nous aide à investir dans ces
régions dans ce process je vais parler
d'un autre front le front politique
d'abord la répression du 20 octobre on
ne peut pas ne pas l'évoquer
officiellement une cinquantaine de morts
et 300 blessés certains parlent de 200
morts une enquête internationale a été
ouverte quelle justice pour les victimes
et leurs familles aujourd'hui écoutez
vous parler de répression mais je
pensais que vous allez d'abord parler de
l'insurrection
qui tendait à déstabiliser les
institutions de la République et face à
cette manifestation contre la
prolongation de la transition locale
[Musique]
insurrection parce que la manifestation
suppose suppose qu'il y ait un intérêt
itinéraire de bien déterminer ce qui
n'est pas le cas les gens ont commencé à
s'organiser
beaucoup plus les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'en fait il y a pas oui on suit avec
nos correspondants à la région
il n'y a pas eu échec
souverain au chat on a eu ce dialogue il
y a une frange et c'est leur liberté de
parties qui ont refusé de participer à
ce dialogue mais c'était parti qui sont
minoritaires qui n'ont aucune existence
sur l'étendue du territoire national il
y a la majorité plus de qualité de
l'appel de l'opposant à manifester de
l'opposant succès à manifester
rassemblée de nombreux manifestants donc
il y a quand même il y a quand même des
partisans et des sympathisants ce sont
quand même des parties qui rassemblent
une certaine frange de la population
puisqu'il y a eu ces manifestations
c'était à l'appel de cette opposition
qui existait
insurrection qui s'en est pris en compte
parce que effectivement c'est une
insurrection parce que une manifestation
de sa capte pas au domicile privé pas au
siège de partie pas aux forces de
défense et de sécurité et pas aux gens
ayant une ayant d'un autre connotation
quelconque c'est ça la réalité une
manifestation ne se commande ne se
démarre pas à 1h du matin
où il n'y aura pas de justice pour les
victimes c'est ce que vous dites juste
pour les victimes y compris du côté les
victimes il y en a partout parce que ce
que vous appelez manifestants mais que
nous appelons
pris à des privés à des personnes qui
n'avaient rien à voir avec le pouvoir il
est parce que simplement ils ont des
noms qui ont des consonance de tel ou
tel province du pays là la communauté le
président de la République a décidé de
mettre d'accepter l'enquête
internationale l'enquête déterminera les
responsabilités dans tous les cas nous
disons que le tchadiens n'ont pas besoin
de de ce genre d'incident parce qu'on a
déjà beaucoup pas faire nous avons
justement Boko Haram à combattre nous
avons le développement nous avons
nos jeunes à qui on doit créer des
emplois et nous avons besoin d'attirer
des investisseurs dans notre pays dont
nous avons besoin de nous unir pour
regarder dans une même direction et
développer merci beaucoup pour votre
message est passé merci Jean-Bernard
padaret donc je rappelle que vous êtes
ministre d'État porte-parole du MPS et
Conseiller à la Présidence merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est moi qui vous remercie
ce forum sécuritaire à Accra au Ghana
cet État d'Afrique de l'Ouest ont entamé
mardi une réunion avec plusieurs
dirigeants européens l'objectif étant
d'accroître leur coopération dans la
lutte contre la propagation du
terrorisme islamiste dans le Sahel vers
les côtes du golfe de Guinée se sommet
intervient à l'heure où plusieurs pays
occidentaux ont annoncé le retrait de
leur troupes dans le maintien de la paix
au Mali après le rapprochement entre la
jointe militaire au pouvoir et Moscou et
au Burkina Faso c'est la France qui
pourrait retirer ses forces spéciales
basées dans le pays le ministre des
Armées Sébastien Lecornu ne l'écarte pas
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré dans le dans un
entretien au JDD le contingent français
installé dans le pays à jouer à un rôle
clé dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
au Sahel mais depuis le deuxième coup
d'État la présence française est de plus
en plus décrié par les autorités et la
population marque pauvre
entre la France et le Burkina Faso le
torchon brut dans les rues de
Ouagadougou les manifestations contre la
présence française sont régulières les
habitants s'en prennent particulièrement
à l'ambassade de France dans une
interview au Journal du dimanche le
ministre des Armées s'est dit près à un
retrait de la force spéciale sabre du
pays
la révision de notre stratégie générale
en Afrique interroge toutes les
composantes de notre présence y compris
les Forces Spéciales nous souhaitons en
effet clarifier en lien avec nos
partenaires la doctrine globale de notre
présence militaire en Afrique Paris veut
ainsi mettre la pression sur le nouveau
gouvernement burkinabè qui multiplie les
critiques à peine voit les contre la
France le contingent sabre regroupe 300
personnes qui ont pour mission
d'éliminer les cibles terroristes à
haute valeur ajoutée qui évolue dans la
zone des trois frontières au Sahel
l'annonce intervient alors que le
gouvernement français veut repenser sa
stratégie en Afrique nos interventions
doivent être mieux bornés dans le temps
et ce dès le début nous n'avons en effet
pas vocation à rester engagée sans
limite de temps dans des opérations
extérieures
c'est aussi pour cette raison que j'ai
décidé en concertation avec nos
partenaires
d'officialiser aujourd'hui la fin de
l'opération barkhane une décision qui
intervient alors que les relations entre
la France et le manie sont devenus
exécrables le 16 août les derniers
soldats français ont ainsi quitté le
pays les ONG financés par la France ont
été interdits au Mali une décision que
regrette Paris la France espère tout de
même maintenir sa présence au Niger
Emmanuel Macron ces données six mois
pour affiner la nouvelle stratégie de la
France dans la région
cette image sans doute la dernière de
Charles Blé Goudé pointant à la CPI la
Cour pénale internationale le président
du COGEP quitte Lahaye après 11 années
au cours desquelles il a été jugé pour
crime contre l'humanité commis en Côte
d'Ivoire lors de la présidentielle de
2010 Charles Blé Goudé sera de retour à
Abidjan samedi l'ancien chef des jeunes
patriotes avait été acquitté début 2019
comme l'ancien président ivoirien
Laurent Gbagbo écoutez-le au micro de
notre correspondante à La Haye Stéphanie
Maupas
je pense que mon histoire avec la CPI se
termine là aujourd'hui
ma responsabilité a été signée a été
située j'étais habité c'est fini je
rentre maintenant avec l'accord des
autorités de mon pays je pense que nous
sommes dans un processus de tourner
définitivement la page je pense que
c'est dans cette langue que le plan de
la République a accepté que je rentre en
Côte d'Ivoire je vais dans un pays que
je laisse derrière moi depuis plus de 11
ans maintenant c'est un genre de saut
dans l'inconnu mais c'est chez moi quand
même que je m'en vais
le président sud-africain Cyril ramaosa
en visite au Royaume-Uni il s'agit du
premier voyage officiel d'un président
sud-africain dans le pays depuis 2010
pendant ce temps en Afrique du Sud la
contestation se poursuit Laurent berceur
[Musique]
le Royaume-Uni déroule le tapis rouge
pour Cyril ramaosa premier chef d'État à
se rendre à Londres sous Charles III le
président sud-africain a été reçu en
grande pompe à Buckingham Palace une
visite cérémonielle et hautement
symbolique pour les deux pays c'est
un renforcement des relations
bilatérales que nous entretenons avec
l'Afrique du Sud et une opportunité de
développer encore plus ses relations
c'était également l'occasion pour Cyril
ramaosa d'oublier un temps la grande
sociale qui s'est vite en Afrique du Sud
mardi des milliers de fonctionnaires ont
participé à des manifestations à travers
le pays pour réclamer une hausse de leur
salaire le gouvernement avait annoncé le
mois dernier une augmentation de 3 %
après un bras de fer acharné avec les
syndicats une offre jugée dérisoire par
de nombreux sud-africains qui subissent
de plein fouet l'inflation et voient
constamment diminuer leur pouvoir
d'achat
nous sommes venus dire que nous ne
voulons pas de ces 3%. l'essence est
trop cher l'électricité est trop cher
nous voulons une augmentation de 10%.
c'est le moins que le gouvernement
puisse faire c'est tout ce que nous
demandons
cela fait plusieurs mois que les grèves
et les manifestations s'enchaînent en
Afrique du Sud après les travailleurs
portuaires et les fonctionnaires les
chauffeurs de taxi sont également
descendus dans la rue lundi pour
dénoncer la suppression d'un programme
d'aide gouvernementale
du monde de football
avoir fait un bon match l'Arabie
saoudite a battu l'Argentine et nous on
a fait un nul avec le Danemark
j'espère que peu à peu nous allons
pouvoir réaliser notre rêve
on ne s'attendait pas à ce résultat
c'est vrai que c'est un match nul mais
on est vraiment content j'espère que
l'on continuera comme ça jusqu'à notre
match contre la France
c'est d'avoir de l'espoir et de croire
en cette équipe et de croire en notre
vie vive la dignité voilà c'est la fin
de journée de l'Afrique rester avec nous
l'info continue sur France 24
[Musique]